Saro I love you too Sonique well Martin
green is proud to star in Space Jam too
no matter what anyone says hey Jim one
was a classic I don't like when people
try to imitate something that was
already good set the record straight on
why fans are gonna love it and why
critics are gonna love it
I will just say I think that everyone is
going to love it okay simple plain
except Charles I love you too what is it
like working opposite LeBron James oh my
goodness it was so much fun I have such
respect for him as we all know he's
quite an inspiring guy and he's all
about that championship living so it was
really such a blessing to be close to
that and I had such a good time with
everyone with with our kids yeah we were
a family really quickly really easily
obvious love basketball always loved
LeBron and so it you know it was he was
wonderful everyone was wonderful what is
the one thing you were most excited for
that dedicated fan base to see when they
finally see the movie when it comes out
oh my I am really excited for them to
see how it's been modernized because I
was really I was really really touched
by that you loved how I wondered I it
was because I wondered the Looney Tunes
are not around anymore and I wondering
how are we gonna make this relevant for
today and they did it in the most
brilliant way I'm very excited so it'll
be something that could be a bridge for
the next generation to the joy folks a
mic stand a total from one reboot to
another Romany Malco revealed if he'd be
down to reprise his role on weeds in the
upcoming TV sequel series lacy LaPlante
a boy said that it means the plant
seemed appropriate yeah why not just
call me Mary Jane dealer I'm on a show
called a million little thing yeah
the ratings on that show are I always
want to be open-minded but I honestly
cannot imagine this show going away
anytime soon
a conrad cameo you know what anything is
possible I'll say that for now Romani
and Seneca are focused on their new
Netflix movie holiday rush about a
wealthy single dad who loses his job and
reduces his family's lavish lifestyles
moving back into our old house what this
movie it's it gives you all the fields
and it's got all the holiday love in it
but it does show you the reality of when
work takes an unfortunate kind of turn
for the worst I do it and I hope the
answer is no but I want to know have you
guys ever been in that position or ever
just like super frustrated about the way
that something went like not getting
apart is there something that stands out
I was a rapper I was on Virgin Records
and I had like a hit I was like the
number-one rap song in the country for a
minute right and there was a point where
I was my labels priority and I was doing
my dream job my dream was to always be a
rapper and it had happened I was touring
all over the country and then one day I
was no longer the priority on that
record label times had changed our deal
had changed and coming to terms with the
fact that it actually happened and not
making it clear to myself that my career
what I was not just my career and she
was so much more human more human and
then and that gave me license to
reinvent because once I came to terms
with it I was no longer afraid of it and
this messed up when you were famous
rapper one day and then you doing craft
service the next day and your boy oh
yeah and your boy is like I thought you
in the movie you doing the craft sir you
serve in the food well hello let me get
a sandwich from you haha right yeah and
I'm doing it well oh no
Jamin that yeah and the reason I did
that was because I saw a lot of my
friends who's been in similar situations
be too prideful to take a job so that
financial stress it transferred to their
families I couldn't be that person so I
was like I'd get a job by the way in
fact I was working with my my girlfriend
at the Times ex-boyfriend cuz he had a
business already dude yeah I can totally
help you
you're like rush you got to do what
happens every step of the way
[Music]